estamos ya en el problema 58 y dice la
gráfica de la ecuación de igual a x
cuadrada menos 3 x menos 4 se muestra
aquí abajo para que valores de x es
igual a 0 muy bien entonces nos muestran
estas cuatro opciones y nos preguntan
cuando llegue es igual a cero entonces
lo que hay que recordar es que ye igual
a cero si nos consideramos no q todos
los puntos en el plano sino aquellos
donde su segunda coordenada de cero
entonces en realidad estamos hablando
del eje x este eje x es del que estamos
hablando en el problema entonces si es
igual a cero en principio uno podría
resolver esta ecuación verdad porque lo
que uno tiene es que que x cuadrada
menos 3 x menos 4 es igual a ye pero en
este caso es 0 entonces uno podría
intentar resolver la ecuación sin
embargo aquí ya nos están dando una
gráfica entonces no es necesario hacerlo
ya que podemos localizarlos muy bien
aquí por ejemplo aquí está la primera
intersección de la
con el eje x verdad que es cuando es
igual a 0 y aquí está el otro entonces x
uno de ellos es menos uno y él y la otra
coordenada es igual a cuatro que
justamente es la opción c muy bien
vámonos con el siguiente problema dice
cuáles de las siguientes gráficas
representa mejor a la de igual a menos
equis cuadrada más 3 entonces para hacer
esto lo que quiero hacer es recordar
cómo se ven las siguientes gráficas
digamos tengo aquí mis ejes coordenadas
aquí está la coordenada y aquí en la
vertical en la coordenada ye la
coordenada x es la horizontal como
siempre y quiero que recordemos quién es
la gráfica de ye igual a equis cuadrada
ye igual a x al cuadrado entonces está
por supuesto es una parábola que tiene
el vértice en el origen en el 00 abre
hacia arriba es la parábola más
es más sencilla que tenemos verdad y en
realidad abre de esta forma porque es
bastante simétrica lo mismo vale si
andamos de las de las x positivas que
desde las x negativas verdad por ejemplo
1 al cuadrado es igual a menos 1 al
cuadrado o si tiene 1 100 al cuadrado es
lo mismo que menos 100 al cuadrado
entonces esto es muy simétrico además
siempre es positivo verdad cualquier
número elevado al cuadrado es positivo
entonces yo espero que ya estés bien
familiarizado con quién es la gráfica de
esta función ahora bien qué pasa si
nosotros nos tomamos ye igual a menos
equis cuadrada esencialmente es la misma
gráfica sólo que ahora todos los valores
van a ser negativos entonces cumple la
misma propiedad de ser muy simétrica
sigue siendo esta parábola solo que
ahora abre hacia abajo verdad son puros
números negativos de hecho pero
podríamos pensar como como si reflejamos
en una espejo la la gráfica de x
cuadrada verdad si esta parábola se ve
al espejo
así es como ella se vería a sí misma
muy bien entonces ya para ir redondeando
quien sería entonces la gráfica de x
cuadrada más 3
muy bien entonces todos los valores me
está diciendo que a todos los valores de
x cuadrada ahora le estamos sumando 3
entonces realmente esto es equivalente a
desplazar nuestra parábola hacia arriba
3 unidades muy bien simplemente está
desplazando la parábola tres unidades
ahora qué pasa si yo tengo que igual que
hay aquí ye igual a x 4 - x cuadrada más
3 pues también la gráfica rosa que es la
que corresponde a menos x cuadrada la
estamos trasladando tres unidades hacia
arriba entonces es exactamente la misma
sólo que desplazada tres unidades hacia
arriba muy bien entonces nos fijamos en
la parábola digamos naranja y nos
fijamos que la opción es la vez verdad
tiene su vértice en él
en el número igual a tres en la
coordenada 03 verdad también es lo que
le llaman la intersección con el eje
y ordenada al origen en fin y además
abre hacia abajo entonces es la única
que cumple esas dos propiedades así que
elegimos la gráfica ve vamos con el
problema 60 cuál de las funciones
cuadráticas al graficar la tiene
intersecciones con el eje x en 4 y menos
3 entonces fíjense que si tomamos una
una ecuación cuadrática si nos tomamos
una ecuación cuadrática en realidad si
interpretamos en x igual a 4 y en x
igual a menos 3 tenemos algo de la
siguiente forma un número que al que
debe al alser 4 se debe anular entonces
es x menos 4 verdad si yo aquí pongo un
44 menos 4 se anula y esto debe
multiplicar a otro factor que estamos
encontrando nuestra función cuadrática
debe multiplicar a un factor que
evaluado en menos 3 se anule entonces si
le sumamos 3 en aquí si x es menos tres
menos tres más tres se anula entonces
más
- en principio más o menos podría ser
esta gráfica pero si nos fijamos aquí no
hay ninguna respuesta que se le parezca
ahora bien si esto es igual a cero
digamos si esto lo igualamos a cero imos
y nosotros multiplicamos lo de la
izquierda de hecho de ambos lados verdad
si multiplicamos de ambos lados por
cualquier constante digamos no se esté
de igual a una constante que multiplica
a x menos 4 x x + 3 si multiplicamos por
una constante distinta de 0 pues la
igualdad se sigue se sigue conservando
verdad entonces realmente esta constante
me permite variar un poquito del
resultado en el sentido de que por
ejemplo esta opción debe aquí esto es 2
veces x 4 verdad sigue teniendo las
mismas raíces por esto que dijimos no
importa si yo tengo aquí una constante
porque después puedo dividir entre esa
constante y regreso a la ecuación
original verdad entonces no importa si
multiplicamos por una constante
en este caso esta constante valdría 2
las raíces siguen siendo las mismas por
lo tanto la respuesta aquí la mejor
respuesta de hecho la única respuesta es
b ok entonces vamos con el siguiente
ejercicio
61 cuántas veces intersectan la gráfica
de igualados x cuadrada menos 2 x 3 al
eje x entonces realmente sabemos que una
parábola pues podría interceptar al eje
x una dos o varias veces verdad por
ejemplo este puede ser algo así como una
parábola de esta forma donde cruza dos
veces puede ser una parábola de esta
forma donde no cruza ninguna o puede ser
una parábola de esta forma verdad algo
así donde cruza solo una vez entonces
cómo determinamos esto bueno pues vamos
a encontrar las raíces utilizando la
fórmula cuadrática o
la solución verdad nosotros sabemos que
es menos b más menos la raíz de b
cuadrada menos 4 ac y todo eso entre 2
entonces entre dos veces a entonces eso
ya lo vimos en la fórmula cuadrática
sólo vamos a irlo aterrizando con estos
números que tenemos que aquí entonces
menos b
- menos 22 más menos la raíz de b
cuadrada que es menos 2 al cuadrado y
eso es 4 menos 44 que multiplica a que
en este caso es 2 y luego multiplicamos
hace que en este caso es 3 sobre dos
veces a que es 2 entonces en vez de 2 le
pongo de una vez 4 entonces fíjense muy
bien esto bueno será igual a 2 + menos
la raíz de 4 menos 3 x 4 son 2 y 12 por
2 son 24 todo esto sobre 4 y 4 menos 24
es menos 20 esto de aquí es menos 20
entonces necesitamos sacar la raíz
cuadrada de un número negativo y eso es
imposible en el conjunto de los números
reales así que como realmente no podemos
obtener una solución real no hay o más
bien hay ninguna solución este
a esa ecuación que es equivalente a
interceptar la gráfica de esta ecuación
cuadrática en cuando y es igual a 0
verdad en la intersección con el eje x
vámonos con el último problema
dice un objeto que es lanzado hacia
abajo con velocidad inicial de 10 por
segundo recorre una distancia s igual a
deporte + 16 t cuadrada donde este es el
tiempo en segundos si benito se
encuentra en un balcón a 84 pies por
encima del suelo y arroja una moneda con
una velocidad inicial de 10 pies por
segundo en cuántos segundos alcanzará el
suelo muy bien entonces vamos a hacer un
pequeño dibujo de eso digamos que aquí
se encuentre benito no sé por qué esté
en un balcón pero hay anda jugando con
sus monedas y deja caer una moneda por
84 84 pies si estás exacto está 84 pies
de altura muy bien entonces nuestra
distancia que va a recorrer es 84 la
pregunta es en cuánto tiempo realmente
tenemos que encontrar la tf ahora bien
la ve que es la velocidad con la que
si la velocidad inicial aquí nos está
diciendo que es de 10 pies por segundo
entonces esto será diez veces este más
16 t cuadrada y tengo que hallar t
porque quiero encontrar el número de
segundos que tardará la moneda en caer
al suelo entonces lo que se me ocurre es
pasar el 84 del lado derecho al restar
de ambos lados 84 entonces tendremos
déjenme déjenme cambiar el orden
tendremos 16 t cuadrada
más y esté eso es esto de aquí de la
derecha
esto es 84 entonces si yo restó 84 de
ambos lados tenemos 16 de cuadrada más
10 de menos 84 igual a cero entonces
esto ya es una ecuación cuadrática
pondremos por ejemplo dividir entre dos
de ambos lados y nos queda 8 t cuadrada
más 5 t menos 42 debe ser igual a 0
también muy bien entonces ya con esto
podemos utilizar nuevamente la fórmula
cuadrática y ver para qué valores debe
tener t entonces sabemos que te tiene
dos valores verdad esto será menos b que
es menos 5 + menos la raíz de de
cuadrada 5 al cuadrado es 25 menos 4 por
8 x menos 42 entonces los menos no lo
voy a poner así menos 4 por 8 por menos
esto sobre dos veces 8 es 16
muy bien entonces seguimos desarrollando
y esto es menos 5 más menos la raíz de
25 y aquí queda claro que el menos por
el menos da más ok entonces va a ser más
4 por 8 32 por 42 entonces 32 por 42
cuánto es 2 por 2 son 4 2 por 3 son 64
por 2 son 8 4 por 3 son 12 4 6 y 8 14 y
llevamos 11 y 2 son 3 mil 344
mil 344 y si le sumamos 25 de una vez
son mil 369 verdad 1300
perdón esto es mil 369
que ya lo estamos
esto va a ser mil 369 y todo esto sobre
16 entonces ahora la pregunta ya
esencial es cuánto es la raíz cuadrada
de mil 369 déjenme sacar la calculadora
entonces mil 369
si le saca ni a qué pasó
y 369 y la raíz cuadrada son 37 entonces
esto es menos 5 + menos 37 sobre 16
ahora bien nosotros necesitamos que el
tiempo sea positivo porque pues no tiene
sentido pensar que en un tiempo negativo
la moneda va a estar en el suelo verdad
no es como que estuviera en el suelo y
saltó ál a la mano de benito están de
acuerdo así que realmente sólo me debo
quedar con el que tiene signo más
y si me quedo solo con el que tiene el
signo más
esto será 37 menos 5 son 32 entre 16 que
son 2 así que la respuesta correcta son
2 segundos lo que tarda la moneda en
caer al suelo muy bien entonces de todas
formas ahora nos veremos en el próximo
vídeo